I was in infant school so I must have
been about five and we had books got
delivered every month so I'm sat next to
this land and he had this bright yellow
book that was about red Indians sorry I
can't say that Native Americans red
Indians at the time I could see they had
an ink drawing of a Native American with
his arm on the ground he was lying down
listening and I you know read enough
even at that age you know he was
listening for things in the distance and
he said no he's he's dead I said he's
not he's listening for things in the
distance and it was in the context of
the chapter it was pretty obvious so it
escalated quite quickly me being me and
I started calling you're thick you're
thick so the teacher came over and um
she basically I was hoping she was this
authority figure and to me even at that
age the truth mattered and she said I
will leave in Paul it's like Everyone's
entitled to their opinion and so yeah
I think from the age of fives you're
talking 50 years later on that's never
left me because I've witnessed it at
universities
and the authorities who are
Guardians of the truth is you know
putting too finer spin on it but the
truth does matter and learning does
matter and they've turned their backs on
it
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
retired academic who's absolutely fed up
of what he's had to deal with his entire
career and he's come on trigonometry to
drop some truth bombs Paul Taylor
welcome to trigonometry sure to be here
thanks very much it's great to have you
on you're going to black pill us about
the state of the academic world uh but
before we get into that tell us who are
you how are you where you are what has
been the journey through life that leads
you to be sitting here talking to us
well until a couple of months ago I was
an academic Leeds University and before
that had been at Salford
um and I studied I did my degree in PhD
at University of Edinburgh
and the reason that I'd split it into
two there's my motivations are wanting
to speak and it was basically I think I
was on the risk of uh having an aneurysm
uh watching the television
and the type of things that are said
it's a very common condition nowadays I
tell you well but we'll get on to
hopefully some of the good aspects of
this so for example I went through a
phase where I kept shouting it's the
sale and bloody Witch Trials and then
Andrew Doyle wrote his book on the new
Puritans so I thought well at least I'm
not going mad
um
and that this is the type of thing and
it's mostly the media's inabilities so
if I can talk about what annoyed me most
about the Mage and I'll try and do that
as quickly as possible but one of my
main points is that the way in which the
media dumbs down everything so I know
that's a bit of an obvious point to make
but I can go into specifics and I just
sometimes think I'm getting a tattoo on
the forehead saying it's more
complicated than that and if there was a
machine to make things unduly simple it
would be places like the BBC which yeah
I can you know you can hands off
commercial TV
um or radio because it's not their remit
to necessarily educate the public
but the BBC it's supposed to be part of
the historical remit and I've just
remember him watching um terrible things
so for example without going into the
politics of brexit which easier said
than done
the level of discourse so have you heard
of Target Two balances
no right if I can remember it stands for
a trans-european automatic real-time
gross settlement Express transfer system
and it's because in the EU when they
used to have float before they had the
Euro you'd have floating exchange rates
so if you're buying loads from a foreign
country your currency depreciate they
become more expensive and this balancing
mechanism the Germans typically export
loads
and this means that in the old days the
Deutsche Mark would have appreciated and
that would have balanced things out
because they got rid of that
they have a paper trail they have within
the EU that everything's in Euro still
has to be paid
so they have nominal balances so the
Germans have this massive Surplus and it
wasn't too bad until about 2008 with the
Lehman banking crisis and then you can
check out that it's a while since I
looked at them but it's about Germany's
owed inverted commas about 1.4 trillion
Euros by the rest of Europe so if for
example a country ever wanted to leave
Italy wanted to leave and I know there's
jokes about the Hotel California
um you can check in but you can't leave
but this is one of the reasons Italy are
on the hook
or they could just reneg but there are
huge balances which show the
inequalities that because of variable
exchange rates are no longer there now
forgive me that it's a slightly
technical economic analysis of what's
going on but it's not insignificant and
if you don't believe me Mario draghi
who's supposed to be you know the
Godfather so to speak of Economics
within the EU he's the go-to man the
fixer he he's got on record to saying
it's one of the most first things he
looks at each morning of the Target Two
balances so these are serious issues now
can you remember in any discussion
um and this idea that the ignorance was
always on one side
when I think it's quite clear I
mentioned it to a few colleagues
um Target what
but they were somehow the the
self-appointed I know you've been
reading Thomas Soul
um I think you've said in the past and
he has this idea about the self-anointed
where the intellectuals give themselves
credit for things they don't know and
act as if they do so that's just the the
the the the default position of the
media as far as I can see
um and there's instances so I I was
getting slightly annoyed I think I'm one
of the Roars and you've had you've had
to go with Aleister Campbell and that
was the other thing that was risking
giving me an aneurysm because you made
the very valid point why has he been
spoken to
um this is a guy who should be in The
Hague not in the television studio and
there's you can find it online he did an
Irish uh something like the late show
and Nigel farage was on with him and
I've only watched a small segment
but the antipathy there's a live
audience the antipathy towards uh Nigel
farage you could cut it with a knife
and at one point this will surprise you
by Aleister Campbell gets quite angry
and is talking over everybody and he
says
um Nigel this is a direct quote Nigel
Nigel own your own [__] and the audience
gives a spontaneous Round of Applause
unless I've just imagined that bit and
I'm thinking own your own [__] is this a
projection
um
just the inability
um the level of way in which civil
discours the way in which to have an
inter not even an intellectual but just
a rational argument
has become completely ruined by people's
um tribal affinities and I'm from by
Blood I'm Irish
and it really does annoy me um the way
in which the Irish
give themselves a free pass on some of
the difficult issues around the EU which
now they're trying to get rid of their
tax Haven status some of these things
might come to the floor well we'll get
on to all of that and your point about
Alistair Campbell and Nigel farage is
quite a funny one because if you think
about public Consciousness which of
those two people is considered more
moral and more evil and more Despicable
and more specifically morally
questionable it is without doubt it's
certainly if you watch the media it
would be Nigel farage a guy who followed
the Democratic process for some people
didn't like what he achieved but that's
what he did Alistair Campbell on the
other hand very different kettle of fish
certainly Iraqis I think would agree
with that but you guys still haven't
answered my question which is what your
what's your background well that's what
academics do
well you might have worked out by now
born and bred in Liverpool and my first
I can give you two little examples of my
first educational experience before I
talk about how terrible the universities
are my mother I think I think they
diagnose it now as severely dyslexic but
it was never I don't think it was too
early in those days so she really
struggled with reading but I think she
transferred she hot housed me so I've
got a very vivid memory of being if
anyone knows Liverpool it's uh chill or
five ways there's chillwall library and
I was Tiny and I was looking up and
there's a big librarian and they
wouldn't give me a library card because
I was far too young
so my mother was all Scouts come on give
him any book any book give him one so he
handed me just an adult non-fiction book
which I promptly read without any
problems at all he thought fair enough
is you took it so that was um a love of
books and when I was kind of like old
father time because I know you for
example constantly you're addicted to
your bloody mobile
um you know your attack is like an
umbilical cord isn't it but those days
what did you have you know wooden toys
and loops and their Hoops whatever no
but there just there wasn't much so you
did and tally was even worse now because
at least you've got the internet now but
um you know there wasn't that much to do
so I read you know
I read
um an absolute hell of a lot and then I
had this very formative experience a
week and I can tell you the story and
then we can just call the interview to a
halt because it just encapsulates
everything I was in infant school so I
must have been about five
and we had uh books got delivered every
month
and it was like you know these book
clubs and it was a big deal and I
remember
um if someone's a bibliophile you've
read the smell of books there's
something about it and it says wood pulp
smell that's still it's like prisoners
bloody madelines but I can smell the
book still
and um we had a night I'm not uh crying
poverty we had a nice house but that
then went to the northern phrase there's
a phrase all fur coat and no knickers so
we had a nice house but we weren't
spoiled as kids so I never got one of
these books
so I'm sat next to this land
who I've subsequently I've now know in
my head excuse the vulgarity as Little
Johnny [__]
and he had this bright yellow book that
was about red Indians oh sorry I can't
say that no Native Americans red Indians
at the time
and it was all about I had a you know
over his fat shoulder I'm looking and um
and it was about India Indian culture
and what they did and I could say they
had an ink drawing of a Native American
with his arm on the ground he was lying
down listening and I you know read
enough even at that age no he was
listening for things in the distance
so he said I mentioned this to him and
he said no he's he's dead I said he's
not he's listening for things in the
distance and it was in the context of
the chapter it was pretty obvious so it
escalated quite quickly me being me
um and I started calling you're thick
you're thick so the teacher came over
and um she basically I was hoping she
was this authority figure and to me even
at that age the truth mattered so I
thought he's not dead He's Alive it's
about Native American culture she's
going to tell him and she said oh leave
him pull it's like Everyone's entitled
to their opinion and so
in that one moment
it was I I think from the age of fives
you're talking 50 years later on that's
never left me because I've witnessed it
at universities
and the authorities who are
Guardians of the truth is you know put
into finer spin on it but the truth does
matter and learning does matter and
they've turned their backs on it so
anyway that was infant school I went to
a it was great I got the 11 plus to do
grammar school in Liverpool and it would
have been a grammar school but it turned
an independent school when I was already
at it because they threatened turning it
into a comp
um so but everyone who's already there
was sorted all your fees were paid and
everything was 11 plus and that we might
get onto that later but that taught me
about the selection procedure because
I benefited from my it was in West Derby
my school but people from all over
Liverpool went to it and it was the top
one or two percent of you know Liverpool
who got to that school so it was just
and I know there are issues about
everyone arguably everyone should be
educated together but there's
undoubtedly advantages when EV the
teacher doesn't have to explain the most
basic things to people
and I experienced this I did maths um
I've always had to think about my
absolutely adore maths but I'm not
particularly good at it I'm going to say
not particularly good I got math throw
level a year early and I got an A
so nationally I was good at maths but in
my I was in the ASAP for math style 34
I'd regularly come 30 or 31st
so it when something was explained to me
in class I knew very quickly that these
people are they're getting in 10 seconds
it's taken me three minutes because I
don't have a comparative advantage on
this topic but that didn't stop me
loving it but that also I've always had
in my life as well educationally this
trade-off between
it sounds like an American outfit
doesn't be the best you can be a versus
everyone should have access so I
understand the Dilemma but I I am a
massive Advocate I think Peter Hitchens
has just done a book called The
Revolution betrayed about grammar
schools and what they achieved and
you know someone like Anton's and you
know
um and now do well from recent times but
you know Liverpool in the 80s
that was rough I'm you know I'm not
kidding bullies from the black stuff all
that type of stuff so I've got Vivid
memories I know it's not Soviet Union
levels of poverty but it was much much
worse
was it was pretty rough but everyone I
knew I was gonna who made it out to
Liverpool but went to a grammar school
and insofar as there was any social
mobility in those days it was grammar
school assisted and I think that's a a
massive argument in Peter Hitchens book
so if I'd ironically if I'd have gone to
my local comprehensive school it would
have been
um I know you don't like class analysis
I like it I'm joking yeah it would have
been much more homogeneous in terms of
the local catchment area so ironically I
went to an independent school that had a
much much better mix of people from
around the city and you've got a sense
of how you know
I was hot housed as a kid to read
um there was never an issue
um you know I weren't putting money in
the electricity meter to get the lights
on which some you know people I studied
with did
um so I I was just very very conscious
but that was their way out was by
education so you know this sounds like
I'm talking about the developing world
but in parts of England specifically
that I know most about that's true
so that was um I did a levels I went on
to do a levels I did and I'll only
mention them because I want to pick up
on some of the themes I did uh Spanish
English literature and economics and we
did everyone did General Studies but the
um English and Spanish
in those days we did about a good third
of it was literature and history so I
did the Conquistadors so I learned all
about that which was fascinating and
what for today's knowledge it's
interesting that when they went to
Mexico I think was Cortez
um they managed to bring down the whole
Aztec empire with very few people a few
Rottweiler dogs and a few horses that
scared the locals but that was because
of various complex reasons the weakness
of the Aztec empire
and the idea that nowadays small vocal
groups are doing so much damage if
there's a rotten culture there's
something wrong with the the dominant
culture
um absolutely catastrophic things can
happen so that's what I got from that
and also um
I did some existential uh Ernesto Sabato
El tunel which was an existential novel
ahead of its time it's better than
sarchin in my humble opinion
um so I got a taste for things like and
just reading in a foreign language
um I think you've done translation work
in the past continent and one of my
frustrations teaching was
let's put it this way if I saw an essay
that was really grammatically really
good
um I'd look to see which part of
Scandinavia they came from
because British students don't have
facility with their own language so the
idea that the tough facility with other
languages I think that's one of the
saddest things about
um
you get lots of good inputs from
overseas students but I think as a the
UK as a whole I think language teachings
getting worse not better in terms of
resources the amount of language
teachers so that was one of the things I
learned and it just brings so much so
maybe later on we'll get on to but I've
started looking at um midrash which is a
Hebrew biblical studies technique and
body of literature because I'm
fascinated by how meaning is constructed
and um
that that approach to language and when
you look at the well hopefully get onto
the issues about the Canon and you know
the books that we should be reading but
when you look at Old Testament or Hebrew
writings
and often it'll have gone from Aramaic
to Hebrew to Greek to English and at
every single point someone's made a
translation judgment
that's got profound consequences on what
the thing means
and if you don't have facility with
language so you know history a
historical context has been driven out
into public discourse language skills
are often limited and the subtlety the
complexity of of what's truly there so
I'll give you one little example before
I go on um there's I think they're
called the wisdom books so I think it's
Ecclesiastes which is also known as
um kohalet
uh Proverbs on the Book of Job And I'd
never I think we're talking off camera
about once you retired you can read all
the things you wanted to read and I
never would have read you know Old
Testament time boring and there's a guy
in America called Robert's alter who's a
Biblical scholar and he's done a
re-translation of the wisdom books and I
think in Ecclesiastes there's a famous
there's a constant phrase oh vanity of
vanities and it's all about things under
the sun
but he translates it as
um
mere breath mere breath and then later
on there's a refrain it's like herding
wind
and it's existential literature
from Two and a Half thousand years ago
um the language is beautiful the meaning
is beautiful
um and but in order to engage with that
you have to have a frame of reference
which that's what those
um the English and the Spanish but
having said all that and this is why
I've learned as of my career progressed
because I've done economics I thought my
father was an accountant I thought well
I'll go off and do an economics and
accounting degree and I'll be sorted for
life so I signed up I did economics and
accounting at Edinburgh
realized very very quickly accountancy
wasn't for me so I managed to do
economics and politics
and through the politics over the years
I've drifted more and more to the
literature which is what I should have
done from the get-go
but in the first year of Edinburgh one
of the highlights for me was
we had a um it was a general course
for basically people across the social
sciences you had to do statistics course
and there was this guy I think you've
spoken in the past Francis about
teachers and the importance of them so
it's that caused no one wants to teach
it was statistics there's a load of
grumpy public school boys and people
like me
and
it was like listening to someone
visually verbally described the visual
manipulations of a Rubik's Cube it was
absolutely wonderful I've never heard
anyone speak about maths the way he did
and I think statistics is quite specific
because it has a social context it's not
pure maths and if you know Neil Ferguson
and the covert Bunch had done any proper
statistics he wouldn't have been in
lockdown for what seemed like five years
um which is you know it's a major issue
people don't do uh stats so
jumping around but that would be if
you're going to say what what's your
recommendation that everyone does I
forget all this government or let's
learn what democracy is every student
that can possibly be force-fed as a
statistics course should be
so you're in agreement with richly soon
act then Paul well specifically
statistics I think he just wants
everyone turn everyone into an
investment banker but if you're going to
be an active citizen
so
we are jumping around now but you you
pointed me in that direction I'm blaming
you
um you know the The Grooming gang
Scandal I remember seeing a discussion
one of the very few discussions on
Channel 4 and I think it was Kathy
Newman
and she was uh talking with is it Nazir
afzal who was the Northwest director of
public prosecutions and he's from a
South Asian
um origin
and at one point
she was trying I think she was trying to
argue and forgive me if it wasn't Kathy
Newman but it sounds like the type of
thing she'd do
she was trying to argue that because the
vast majority of child abusers are wise
that it's completely unfair to focus on
the grooming gang scandal
and I'm thinking the overwhelming number
of child abusers are wise because the
overwhelming numbers still in this
country are wise so it's your selection
categories
um and then she she actually said um he
said um it's undeniable that the
overwhelming
um demographic of these child abusers
are South Asian men of South Asian
origin and I remember she said that's a
bold statement
thinking really no that's a statement of
basic truth but anyway so that
statistics would have helped massively
if Channel 4 reporters had ever done any
or paid attention and that would help in
serious issues like that but then in
second year the highlight of my whole
University career and you might like
this content I did a year-long course on
19th century Russian studies and that
involved literature and history
and unlike today
it was it was a year long
um so you didn't do these little bitty
you know did module here in a module uh
here's a module there's a module
everywhere um it was just wonderful and
we did it wasn't just oh you'll do
um Tolstoy and that's it
we went from Google to geniev lermanoff
we did all the Dostoevsky we did a War
and Peace we did Anna Karenina that was
half the course
the real the half was history so the
intellectual ambition and scope and you
got people from within the humanities
and social sciences got to do it
in today's universities you can do like
Discovery courses or something and you'd
be lucky they'd probably give you a few
chapters of War and Peace because
obviously the whole books far too tiring
um and too difficult so that in those
days what really struck me compared to
now was the level of intellectual
ambition
talk to us briefly about your academic
career because we haven't got there yet
right I'll get to that I'll get to the
point then so I um went from Edinburgh
to Salford I spent I wrote some books on
my PhD sorry I didn't mean PhD Edinburgh
that was on computer hacking and that it
was interesting I struggled to get I got
the PHD published but it took a while
because they said I love the logic they
said because no one's written on
computer hackers before we don't have a
market for it
which I thought was a bit odd because
surely they want to sell things that
haven't been written about but it was a
sociological study of hackers or as I
would say hackers and how they went
about no one had um done that before so
that was quite interesting then I did a
book on activism which is politically
motivated hacking and that was all that
Salford based upon the PHD and then I
moved more into
um so what's interesting about that is
in my early academic career
and in the PHD it was about how people
interact with and try and control
technology so I wasn't arguing that
technology dominates us I was actively
trying to seek ways in which people can
take control of Technology but as my
academic career progressed I realized
more and more I became much more of a
determinist I think technology has very
determining features that are massively
underestimated so I moved more into
what's known as the culture industry
what's known as ironically it's
portrayed nowadays as cultural Marxism
Frankfurt School I wrote a book called
critical within a co-author called
critical theories of mass media then and
now so it was in the past and brought up
to the modern era
and then I got um I moved to Leeds and
got very interested in slavoy zizek's
work again labeled by some as a cultural
Marxist so what makes my career slightly
unusual is
I've studied technology in depth from a
sociological point of view but I'm a
very very critical and I think
universities use technology in ways that
quite unthinking and uncritical I've
done a lot of cultural Marxism
um we used to sit there in Edinburgh and
it was like it was like the Bible I
remember specifically the edition of Das
Capital it was paper thin tissue paper
we'd all rather ever reverentially go
through it line by line
um it was John Holloway taught me there
who was quite a well-known Marxist so
I've got all this Marx's background
and I treat it more as literature to
them
to me
um it's fascinating
analysis of capitalism
but the idea that the assumptions are
often bonkers
the analysis is great and the
conclusions are bumpers with legs on
um so I I'm in this slightly interesting
situation where I'm immersed in this
type of stuff but simultaneously very
critical of it but I also think it gets
a very
um sum of the so-called post-modern
stuff gets a very bad rap and is
profoundly misunderstood
and my sense is that if we're gonna some
of the issues you talk about on the show
about
how do we break through how do we have
this
um rational discourse in good faith how
do we relate to each other better how do
we have proper debates
one of the things you might want to talk
about is the way in which people don't
understand
the things they're labeling so I'm a
massive fan of Douglas Murray
but I think he's on certain issues about
I think he's doing what Richard Brannan
would call
um Shadow work on post-modernism
I think he's misrepresented it and he's
put on loads of bogeyman aspects
interestingly Andrew Doyle doesn't do
this I think Andrew does got a doctorate
and whenever I've heard him and I've
read he's very very cautious about he
doesn't blame post-modernism I think he
distinguishes in post-modernism applied
post-modernism so people have made a
mess of and I can relate to that because
my book Christopher is a massive media
then and now it was translated into
Farsi
and I was interviewed by someone from
I'm not exaggerating he was someone
linked with the Revolutionary Council
because retrospectively thinking about
it I was having a go at Western
capitalist media
from a very critical point of view so if
there's ever another you know Revolution
with the ayatollahs my book might be
waved
Tehran but my point is you don't know
how your work's going to be used you
don't know how your work is going to be
misinterpreted and what I think is
interesting is if it was
if the Ivory Tower was the old-fashioned
Ivory Tower
that was quite tightly circumscribed and
the weren't so when I went to University
in 1985 I think it was about 12 of
people went to University now it's a
good 50 percent
and you know some of the concerns you've
discussed on this show about how bad
ideas percolate into society at Large
well first of all the Ivory Tower was
more ring fenced
and I think Oscar Wilde said you know
the stupidity of professors is long
studied for and earned but those stupid
ideas I absolutely I've spent a bit of
time with slavoy Zizek I was The
Unofficial tour manager when he gave
some talks in the north of England
but I wouldn't trust him to run a bath
never mind run a country
so the idea that you use some of their
ideas and you you see that
as some type of guidance for societal
policy and stuff it's brilliant
intellectually I think David Starkey
made the point
that I am
conservative thinkers aren't
particularly interesting
because their intellectual ambition by
definition is limited to conserving
things
whereas the wacky post-modern it well we
could talk about them potentially later
on postmodernism because I don't even
think necessarily they're left-wing
which is another misunderstanding
but lots of left-wing you can have
um ridiculous ideas of where you could
take theory in a practical sense you've
had to suffer that the Soviet Union
but I don't see necessarily why it has
to be that way and why we have to take
these ideas
it's the lack of filtering it is one of
the ironies that the more you've
expanded the universities the more
you've let all that
toxic theoretical discharge get into
society it doesn't have to be toxic but
it can be
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
fascinating and the breakdown and
explaining what's been going on and your
own experiences
to someone who is listening to this and
didn't go to university
intellectually curious what is what what
is post-modernism explain to that person
what post-modernism is
and then the effects that it's having on
society particularly Universities at the
moment right it sounds like an academic
answer but one of the problems is if you
ask what post-modernism is it's defined
by various people in various ways so
I'll give you my definition but there
will be people who disagree and this is
one of the frustrating things if no one
can agree on the definition how do you
analyze it very post-modern right
exactly but I think the shortest version
would be to say that it's it's a
response to modernism and I think that's
also one of the misapper engines
modernism defined as in art and culture
uh highly technologized societies so you
know Duchamp I think um David Starkey
talked about that
fragmentation of technological Society
modernist art was trying to represent
that or engage with it
and for me post-modernism or
intellectuals struggling to think well
how do we given this fragmentation so
Samuel Beckett people like that uh
search of the existentialists everyone's
trying to make sense of what this
technological Society has done and they
came up against a brick wall with
existentialism so Sartre wrote a
critique of dialectical reason which
took existentialism and tried to make it
Marxist
um
who else
T.S Elliot something what's one of the
owners he was a conservative
but in his poetry uh you know the
Wasteland you know this isn't news but
it's not full of giggles and laughs it's
dark dark stuff
um the hollow man it describes my career
actually I think at one point in the
Holloman they say this is how the world
ends not with a bang but a whimper
um mine ended my career ended with I did
an online class where none of the
students show their faces
so it was like some very ugly narcissors
looking in this screen this pool looking
back at myself
um and one by one these non-faces with
just a name disappeared off the screen
and that was my last lecture ever so so
that was nice but I mean
modernism is what it's reacting to
and it's trying to make sense of that
so there was a article in the telegraph
by the time this goes out it wouldn't
maybe about two Thursdays ago Nick
Timothy who you might remember the name
he was an advisor to Theresa May so this
is a bit like the right-wing version of
Aleister Campbell
given Nick Timothy's performance as a
political advisor how does he get the
gig writing for National newspaper
um he didn't seem to go very well with
Teresa but he does he does a anti-blames
post-modernism as people tend to do and
he mentioned specifically Foucault and
derida
now so are you okay I can explain
differently but if you took Foucault and
darede this is someone writing in a
national newspaper there his definition
of what post-modern thinkers are
Foucault and Douglas Murray's written
negatively about fuka but fuka was a
French thinker who's trying to make
sense of this these modern Trends the
alienating aspects of Technology
and what he did was look at various
epochs in history he called them
epistemes
and his argument was that
it's a um what we can say intellectually
how you conceptualize things is
dominated by ways of thinking that you
may not even realize you're being
circumscribed by so if you took it back
to classical times they had Notions of
virtue
they had Notions of Honor
that we just don't have
so Socrates famously died
he got offered a chance to escape he
refused because he said it was honor if
you look at their Sophocles and Antigone
this is a story of a woman who um it's a
big internet signed conflict in a Greek
city-state but her brother gets killed
he tries to have a coup and the the the
customer at the time was you have to
bury your relations
and it was word was put out he's lying
outside the city if anyone tries to bury
him
they will be killed and she buries him
it says Sanju it's my blood I have to
bury him that is the law
so she goes to the wall for the law
there's the Spartans you know the Battle
of them up a line there's that famous uh
thing oh stranger passing by was it a
stranger passing by go tell the Spartans
loyal to the our customs here we lie so
they all died because they didn't want
to portray what it was to be a Spartan
so that's an example of classical times
modern times we don't think in that way
so one of the obvious arguments is you
know that the post-modernists are
defined as being relativists there's no
absolute truth nothing really matters
and I just think it's a massive
mischaracterization
Richard rorty is another post-modernist
and he was someone said tomorrow you
were post-modernist or a nihilist
and he said neither I'm an ethnocentrist
and what he meant by that was he said he
found American
Democratic Values it was very unusual
for doing this he said American
democratic values or actually what's
worked the best so he didn't believe in
truth and he quipped he got taken up
through it was I think it was mostly
joking he said the truth is what your
peers will allow you to get away with
saying
but he had this strong sense of like
science all knowledge is tested and in
any given environment the truth will be
what survives the testing process
so Einstein eventually overtook at a
subatomic level Newtonian physics
doesn't work so Newtonian physics was
the episteme it was the way of thinking
and that controlled how we were able to
think about gravity
Einstein comes along and actually he's
Rewritten and that's still using
technology now
uh there was something in the paper
about in a black hole they're finding
that um Einstein's theory is being born
out they can see what's happening but
they think they might be coming to the
point where Einstein's theory is
stretched to the Limit
so that's a fukuian idea
now I don't know what you think I don't
see the idea that truth is relative
they mean it in quite a specific way
um and darada is the other guy he's
often labeled as he doesn't believe in a
concept of Truth what he actually means
is
Things Are incommensurable
so one of the examples is a brilliant
guy if people want to check this out
because it is complicated but there's a
guy called
um Chris Watkin
who he's like my uh doppelganger I'm
like
um Dr Jekyll he's like Mr Hyde he's
really nice and he'll say things like
he'll be asked a really stupid question
and he'll say that's a wonderful helpful
question thank you and then explain it
but he does he's from the Reformed
Church so he's actually a
hard-carrying battle-waving Christian
and he engages with DeRidder and
Foucault and applies them to Old
Biblical scriptures
and he makes the point that um with
dareda it's like saying um if someone
nearest and dearest to you you said how
much would it take before your degree to
have them killed
and this is a bad question for me
because I just have a tariff you just
take notes
that's comforting thanks mate I think
the point Chris Watkins trying to make
is that we'll actually
you can't put a volume on your nearest
an incrementable question so in that
sense truth is relative and that's the
short version it'll give lots of ethical
examples from Christianity
do you think this is part of the problem
though in that we are talking about
these topics whether it's post-modernism
whether it's all of these you know big
terms and schools of thought and then
people are talking about them in the
media people are talking about them in
their workplace and the problem is is
that most people to put it bluntly
haven't done the reading and they're
having discussions about things that
they fundamentally don't understand well
it's Richard Gran an interview I'll take
you back to that and it was interesting
I know I don't think it was you're
making a serious Point constantly but
you did say at one point thinking isn't
power
um so give me some practical examples
and Richard Brannon did the Chris Watkin
thing well thank you and and but then if
you actually listen to what he said he
basically he's saying it was a stupid
question what he actually then went on
to say was we need to think more
and we need to have the Socratic method
and there's a point that Theodore Dorner
has this beautiful phrase where he said
when the doors are barricaded it's
doubly important thought not be
interrupted
and it's one of the points of that is
that when it's all kicking off
like Newcastle on a Saturday nights it's
you people have this reaction it's like
let's go and do something
and often they go down the wrong so I'll
give you one very specific hopefully
helpful example to listeners or viewers
uh Bob Geldof Live Aid
he did this remember him swearing it I
remember the originally swearing at the
television saying you know no don't
bother about credit cards sending cash
or something's going you know swearing
in his Irish accent
fast forward he's on the Thames lobbying
abuse at Nigel farage about the EU
now
the whole point about Live Aid was
you're dealing with the symptom of
African poverty
now I'd argue from an economic having an
economics background one of the major
problems of African poverty not
everything but a major element is
African Farmers have never been able to
compete on an equal playing field with
places like the EU why because it's not
they don't have free access
there's tariffs
so if Bob Geldof wanted to do one
practical thing if you genuinely cared
about the African people he'd be banging
on the doors in Brussels saying give
African Farmers access
and that would but no we want Italian
French farmers to be subsidized
so that was the point about
Bob Geldof did something incredibly
practical he got off his backside people
will Lord him
but then he seems completely oblivious
because he's a celebrity
and he's famous for being famous
um he's not stupid but also I don't
think he's half as bright as he thinks
he is
and another example would be either
please indulge I want to get this off my
chest did you have you ever seen there's
a Norwegian I think Swedish
co-production called scavalin he was a
journalist and they're on YouTube he did
the series of interviews with quite big
names
um
so Jordan Peterson Richard Dawkins these
type of people he'd interview and he had
Jarvis Cocker on
and it's all done in English you know
which was helpful
um but Jarvis Cocker went on this rant
about brexit
and he was saying it was
uh what was he saying basically he made
analogies with the music industry and
said that occasionally you'll get a
a record that will get to number one
from nowhere and he said it's very dodgy
and he didn't really have an argument
apart from it overwhelmingly what came
across was Jarvis Cocker didn't like the
fact that Britain had voted to leave the
EU and you can ask many questions about
that but one is why do we care what
Jarvis Cocker thinks he gets that
platform because he's made the song
ironically called common people so he
claims to understand common people
and I just thought you know
what an absolute tosser you've
completely
misunderstood and if I can ask you to a
question you know um You probably won't
be aware but you know the Welsh voted
for the evolution in 1997.
um so they had a Welsh assembly do you
know what the turnout was
it was I think it was 50.2 percent of
the people turned out do you know what
the majority it was a binary question do
you want a Welsh assembly or do you not
you know what the the winning percentage
was null to 0.6 percent
and guess what
we've got a Welsh assembly without a big
fuss well because it that was it was a
selfie it was explained this is the
question
there weren't any limits it was only
just 50 of the population if you don't
care enough to vote you don't have a say
Winner Takes on I can't I've never ever
seen anyone in any media format complain
that this was a travesty or a stitch up
so Jarvis well it's one of the the Gen
if you look at the Genesis of
trigonometry with me and Francis one of
the things that we both found and I use
it I don't use this term lightly I was
disgusted by the way that people reacted
to their and by the way as you well know
Francis and I both voted to remain in
that referendum but the idea that
because you didn't get the result you
wanted out of a referendum that you are
entitled to undermine the result that
you're entitled to try to overturn the
result I mean I've told the story before
but I'll tell it again I was in a having
a meal with some friends from my
translation days
uh when I was in in Edinburgh for the
festival and uh there was a French girl
there and she was what I don't know what
the problem is in France we had the vote
and uh it did not go away so we did it
again
and she looked at me as if I was
supposed to like clap along to this it
was outrageous and and I completely
agree with you sorry but just as you're
saying that there was a documentary of
Francois Hollande was interviewed and I
think it might have even been a BBC
documentary when I still watch the BBC
it's how long ago it was and he
basically said to the interviewer why
did you not just ignore the vote
and it was cold seriousness it's your
point this is how these people think and
so for us as two people who actually
believe in democracy and in Fair Play
and Justice and which are all British
values by the way that we've seemed to
have forgotten about uh we were both
indignant of that in itself and then of
course the other thing which is anyone
who disagrees with me is a massive
racist and all of that just complete
lies and I felt very uh
I was disgusted by it you can't just
I mean when democracy does not go your
way whether that's Donald Trump and his
non-election right or brexit or whatever
democracy relies on losers consent
that's what that's about and the moment
you start messing with that program
you're going down a very dark path very
very quickly so I hear you on that but
coming back to your point about uh
thinking versus doing I think what I
what we were talking about with Richard
is that
I agree with you that when we're talking
about and I want to ask you about what
you think is actually going on uh
because it's not post-modernism in your
conception the fact of the matter is
that no matter what ideas you have at
the end of the day that is not going to
change reality out there right if you're
concerned about the University or you're
concerned about the media or if you're
concerned about any of those things
there is something that you're going to
have to do once you've decided what that
is once you've thought about it once
you've had the ideas and conceptions and
structures and whatever someone
somewhere is going to have to do
something to change those things and so
for me for example with the media what
you're talking about is we are sitting
right here doing this we are changing
the media by doing this if we were just
thinking if you were sitting at home and
he was sitting at home and I was sitting
at home and we were having ideas about
how the media ought to be different we'd
be in a very different position because
this wouldn't exist and people wouldn't
be watching this and they wouldn't go oh
three people can sit down and have a
rational conversation for an hour and so
I think doing and thinking they they
will go hand in hand what you're talking
about is very much the Thomas Soul thing
which is people who do things that make
them feel good instead of things that
actually make the right difference I
think what I'm also doing is I totally
agree and I was I knew when you were
talking with Richard it wasn't it it
wasn't the point I wasn't trying to
misrepresent it yeah but it wasn't the
only aspect you were mentioning yeah and
I totally and I think David Starkey
mentioned about it's like being under an
elephant you can poke the irony is I'm
retired I've wanted to come into the
music MC Hammer Can't Touch This
sad yes yes the fact that I'm here
because and I did to be fair to me which
I do like to be I was writing in the 19
uh the turn of the 2000s 2003 I wrote an
article about the bureaucracy and Frank
ferrady's you know ignore me go and read
a lot of his stuff he'd been writing
about this book after book after book
so this has been going on but was like
I'm not sure I'm disagreeing with you
but it's just that yeah doing all this
stuff is but one point I'd make is
the fact that you're having to do this
you're taking risks you're being
entrepreneurial where all three of us I
think I should all pay just about pay
tax we're paying for a national
broadcaster to insult us on a daily
basis that gets my goals I get it so
apart from anything else I I I demand my
right not to pay to be insulted I agree
with you but but my point is to you is
thinking about that and being indignant
about isn't going to change anything
right no no I totally agree with that
but but anyway let's not let's not dwell
on that because actually I I think the
most fascinating question to ask you
is what you think is going on in the
world where is all this stuff that we
talk about on the show the stuff that is
destroying universities a step at a time
what is going on and where's that come
from well it relates to what we've just
been talking about in the sense I get
the sense and you chip in if you think
I'm going off on one but it's this we go
around in circles that's why I mention
the misrepresentation in my view of what
post-modernism is but if I just throw
out another idea if I say to you anyone
heard of Nietzsche a lot of people if
they have heard them will say oh yeah
isn't that the guy who ended up snugging
holes and went mad
I'm just that one little example he the
accusation he snogged the Halls because
he had syphilis I think is the what goes
around the syphilis has never been
confirmed and it's actually highly
unlikely because this isn't from
personal experience but tertiary
syphilis tertiary cephalus takes about
two or three years to hit he had 11
years before he died
but he went Gaga but they think it was a
benign tumor potentially or they they've
looked at his medical records and tried
to tertiary syphilis was the default
diagnosis so that's just one little
example it was the covet of its day
but at least you enjoyed getting
syphilis
well but francis's point is that people
are using terms they don't know about
yes so a very quick answer to what
you're saying is I think what's
dominating
the the problem in our society is
there's a not even it sounds like
conspiracy theorists there's a
technocratic and to call them an elite
is wrong because they're heraldically
bad at their jobs but I can't I can't
think of a major institution I was
moaning to you off camera about the
situation our train system
but there are managers to the gills in
all major institutions in this country
who on a routine regular basis
call punch though out of a wet paper bag
and Mike but they will give you
tabulations they will give you
formulations it's the Neil Ferguson
effect of covert
that isn't any system we have apparently
to hold these people to account so
Andrew doll's been in this chair and
said that it doesn't matter if you vote
we should have a party you're not
getting genuine left or eyes what you're
getting
and it reminded me of I saw an interview
Douglas Murray did with advising advice
is in the Lords now but I think at one
point advisee was culture secretary
and it made me think talking about
nature made me think of Nature's last
man
um Douglas Murray you know false good
things I I happen to think he's very
good at a lot of what he does
when he was arguing with advaisy it just
became so apparent to me uh Douglas had
integrity
he had a rational argument that everyone
can agree or disagree with but you know
what he's saying and he was arguing I
think the discussion was about the Tate
Gallery and they were decolonizing I saw
that interview yeah he was very good in
that yeah but advice he wasn't no and
I'd ask you why do you think Ed vasey
wasn't my answer would be because he's a
time-serving technocrat he's gone to the
Lords
I'd have a different answer for you well
my view is he's a time-serving
technocrat he's part of a club I'll give
you a different example that Francis
might be more interested in uh Angela
Rayner
professional northerner so she's in the
Commons never loses an opportunity
um
have you heard her say one single thing
about the grooming gangs no
as a woman a white woman from the north
of England
it's jaw dropping and my answer why
she's never said anything if she has I
apologize but she's certainly not said
it in a high profile forum
because she's part of a club whether
you're conservative lib damn labor even
SNP you're part of a club you've got all
these perks you're you're performing in
the media Realm
they're not engaging with genuine truth
they're not engaging with genuine
politics So my answer to your question
is what's going on we're going around in
a loop where Concepts don't have genuine
depth because people don't understand
the terms they're using or they do and
they deliberately misuse them
so we could talk about another time but
I think Stephen hex I don't think you
like him but his analysis of
post-modernism is just off the scale
wrong
or at least if he was prepared to say
this is applied uh post-modernism and
its people have taken some ideas mashed
them up and made a complete mess of them
then I'd agree with him but the way in
which he talks about some of these
Trends
um I just think is profoundly wrong
um but that's led to and I get what
you're saying about doing things but one
of I think the strongest arguments you
and Francis keep putting forward is we
need rational argument in good faith who
could disagree with that
and I'm not joking this is what I was
going to say sorry no no no I I think
this is fascinating by the way I'm sure
it would be very interesting to talk to
Stephen Hicks about and maybe even have
both of you on at the same time
um for an interview that would be
watched by about three people uh about
the depths of post-modernism but
I think the reason these people operate
in the way that they do and I I think
about this because you know I'm
interested in debating ideas and
communicating ideas and and so on I
think they are captured by an ideology
that essentially prevents them from
seeking the truth and so if you're at
vasier and you're talking about that
particular issue what that issue is
really about they were talking about the
tape but it was in the context of
slavery racism and all of that right
racism sexism uh trans there are a few
issues on which if you're part of this
sort of liberal Illy in an inverted
commas you have not irrationally derived
opinion but received wisdom you must
think about this this is where the
Mantra trans women are women comes from
nobody who's ever thought about biology
Anatomy rationality human nature men and
women childbirth any aspect of humanity
that is actually real could possibly
make that statement in good faith it is
a statement of faith it is a statement
of ideological adherence did I just jump
in there slightly correctly it's not
good it's not Faith it's bad faith
what I mean is it's a belief rather than
a rationally derived opinion yeah but
except and then with someone like
advising my point is he's intelligence
that this is what makes it worse if I
thought advaisy believed a word he said
I'd have a little bit more respect I
believe I believe that he does believe
what it is he's bright enough
he knows what he's doing and that's what
saddens me
no one
um
it just came into my mind as I'm
speaking that one of the things that I
finally stopped watching the baby say I
will watch when you're on question time
then I'll have to find where I've put it
on me widescreen TV little
um thing but Robert Winston so this is
one of the issues like how do you talk
about things yes yeah Robert Winston you
can I can withdraw about postmoderners
and people think what's he going on
about no Mark very minor career Robert
Winston it's like if God gave you the
most respected biologist in this country
it would be Robert Winston yes he's on
question time he gave what I thought I'm
not being critical
Anodyne answer about because he was
asked about this trans issue about
chromosomes he explained the basic
biology about chromosomes Fiona Bruce
who's the Kathy Newman of the BBC so
what you're saying is
um what's Fiona Bruce then said was when
they passed over the question I think I
need to point out at this point there
will be some viewers at home who are
offend by what you've just said
how can you be offended by the country's
most eminent biologist giving you a
couple of lines from what used to be a
basic biology textbook
to me go sorry go for it and I'll make
my point if an academic at that standard
is reduced to not being not even going
Beyond a basic a-level Biology book but
then having so he's it's in for a dig
he's performing at a level exponentially
below his intellectual capability when
it comes to biology and even at that low
level he's been told by a numbnut
um presenter who thinks because she's
sat in the church she's the controller
of the knowledge
he's been corrected
so my this is what I'd add to the
discussion is how do you have any type
of rational debate when the people most
qualified even in good faith he wasn't
saying anything nasty they're shut down
or they're told that your argument is
not valid where does this rational
debate occur yeah
it's got to occur outside of these
institutions because the institutions
are corrupted therefore you can't have
good faith rational debate in them
because they will be shut down through
the tools that we all know that that
they use so it has to be in places like
this but I would also say to you Paul
there's also a biological element to
this which is we are programmed to be
part of a tribe we are programmed to
want to be accepted because in the days
of the African Savannah being expelled
from the tribe meant death and then
being on your own and me not being able
to hunt you'd be dead within days
so we don't want to be expelled from the
tribe we don't want to be ostracized we
don't want to be alienated it's
hardwired into us so to go against the
grain to stand up against a mob that is
a Preserve of very few people who in my
dare I say uneducated point of view that
to me is almost overriding your biology
but the trouble I have with that
argument is that it's the mob and this
is the role in my background in studying
technology and you'll well know the mob
is the vocal mob on Twitter
no but it's not but it's also but but
the mob I also mean the people for
instance let's say you do let's say you
say trans women aren't women I don't
let's say you would work at a BBC you
say look I don't believe trans women or
women I believe a woman is an adult
human female now 10 years ago that is
10 years ago people would look at you
like you were a [__] weird yeah what
you're saying sorry I'm just I'm just
clarifying your mob though I think what
you mean is it's the institution of the
BBC and the dominant culture but it's
yeah it's it is it's a dominant culture
but it's also the fear that there are
people within that in institution who
you may not even know who may be nice to
your face who when they hear you say
that will try and get you fired as a
result but that's not my mom's like I'm
not being done to him probably will
sound pedantic but what I'm trying to
say is that is not a mob as I understand
a mob my frustration is you're what
you're totally correct what you're
describing though is an institution that
is failing at its most basic level the
managers are failing agreed the people
yeah but this isn't a mob people are
scared because they don't want to be
part of the tribe this is a Thomas Soul
self-anointed mini tribe agreed who are
consciously and deliberately
imposing their values on the country I
agreed I agree and when I was I tell you
the story because it very much fits this
narrative uh I have a foreign name I
have dark skin I look a bit different
I'm clearly not British blah blah blah
blah and I used to go in and do this
radio program on the BBC when I was
doing stand-up a couple of nights a week
and uh they'd invite me on and there was
this young woman there who works at the
BBC who would co-host her with me and
because I have a foreign name and uh she
she'd assume I'm one of them
and the way they talk about these things
some of them at least at the BBC I mean
they don't you think that these people
don't understand
that rather they pretend that what
they're saying is one thing but then
something else no no they're True
Believers and she was saying to me well
now now we've got now we're in charge
you know it's about Equity it's about
diversity it's like that's how they
think they think that the country is
overrun by people like you racist
bigoted Northerners right who are a bit
uh you know uh and uh finally we have
the opportunity to take Britain into the
21st century that's how they think they
think that this is our time we are the
revolutionaries they're not
sitting there you know going oh we're
gonna do some evil [__] here they think
they're improving the world they are
True Believers and in terms of you know
the majority minority whoever look the
history of the world's you know this
better than me the history of the world
is always determined by a small group of
people uh who who who sees the Public's
imagination who sees the means of
control over that Society whatever it is
uh there's a great um speech that
Bridget Gabriel gave about Islamic
extremism I don't know if you've ever
seen this it's one of the most powerful
speeches you ever heard I'm talking
about this that you know the history of
the world has changed by a small group
of people who
um who believe very strongly in what
they believe in and they seize the the
means of production in in in in Marx's
language yeah I think what I'd add to
that though is a slightly different
perspective I think you know um Hannah
Arendt wrote um the banality of evil yes
and if I got to chat with her if she was
alive I'd say I think you should have
called it the evil of banality yes
because
it's the banal nature of what's going on
yes yeah so I'll give you an example
um because I appreciate it can all be
Airy fairy if we're not careful and it
probably already has been but a very
specific example if you because I think
the university is a dire situation and
listeners or viewers may think are
always better I'm not
um because he's retired didn't go the
way he wanted to but I'd suggest go to
the university of Leeds website they've
got a initiative inverted commas
redefining the curriculum
which I think you probably can work out
what this is
and they've got a load of people doing a
professionally produced video
and it reminds me are you familiar with
David Sedaris yes he's an American
raccoon to uh very funny guy he's got
quite a squeaky voice yes and tells
stories and whatever he tells them in
front of an audience it's brilliant but
he he was a journalist and he um did a
an article for something called Stadium
mate
and basically it's a bizarre example but
it was um it's basically a catheter so
you go to a big sports event in America
and I'm not judging Americans but some
of them are quite poorly and they're
they've got their jumbo Coke and the
massive burgers and everything and they
don't have to go the toilet so you can
go in your chair into your
Stadium Maze and he said he was testing
it you know he was tested I don't think
he ever took off but there's a surprise
but the look on your face is what I was
gonna say yeah he tested it and he said
he was he was checking into a hotel
somewhere and he said in theory you just
go whenever you want and he said but he
was just about to check in and he
decided to have a widdle
and he said
the person who's serving at the counter
of the hotel knew what he was doing
and he knew what he was doing because he
had this thousands yard stare
and why I say that is you look at this
video These University of Leeds
employees
are mouthing inanities about we are
going to make the curriculum available
to everyone dumbing down
um etc etc and they have this look
and there's a brilliant brilliant book
it's not I think it's been reissued
because I've got a relatively modern
copy but this guy called Robert J lifton
and it was called thought reform
the psychology of totalism and I think
the subtitle was brainwashing in China
and he was an American psychiatrist in
the Army and in the 1950s it was the
books published in the 1960s but he did
his research 1950s because I know you've
got your Soviet background
um
and those that I could mention examples
from the Nazi periods of you know this
totalitarian and maybe the Chinese
example doesn't get spoken of enough
but he did this study
um of basically brainwashed I think in
Chinese that she now
um and there'll be Mandarin speakers at
home thinking why has he just ordered a
bowl of noodles but I think it literally
means wash brain and he got these people
who'd been brainwashed and they were
tended to be a Catholic priests or
general Christian clergy
um and at the back of the book it's
called chin Huen Lin
is the he was the most eminent professor
of formal logic I think it was probably
Beijing University and he did a um
a confession a written confession and he
publishes it in the appendix
and one of the things that mentioned in
China they did curriculum reform
and he gets accused and this is why I
get slightly defensive when people go on
about post-modernism because he's
accused he has to do this explanation
where he says I was accused I I have
played um concept games I am guilty
because I should have only thought in a
way that helped the People's Republic
um so the idea was there are limits to
how you can think and I'll just make the
suggestion when people are slagging off
postmoderns and just be aware
telling people the limits to which they
should take thought has a bad Heritage
as well as well as the misuse of these
things in totalitarian societies
so in Victor klemprev the Nazi example
he was a Jewish philologist a study of
language and he makes he's done a book
called the language of the Third Reich
and it's a it's poignant as hell because
the very beginning is he talks about
Greek definitions of heroism in the
classics
and he makes the point that at the most
Brave EX in Germany at the time heroism
that was the word that was used like
today there are buzzwords and he said
his wife was um so-called Aryan and he
was Jewish so he said she her life was
worse it was unbelievably bad because
she was voluntarily giving up all her
Privileges and being spatter in the
streets and I know it's not worse just
because she didn't happen to be Jewish
but she was not Jewish and could have
just walked away and she went through
all this as he said that is heroism but
one of the things he says was we have
this misunderstanding you know
propaganda is so powerful he said he'd
be he'd be sat there in an apartment and
just observing uh non-jewish Germans and
the radio would be on with Goebbels
and people weren't listening
and you said they were talking about
what they were going to get the shops
the next day but he said what did have
an effect
as a professional philologist he noticed
certain words got redefined
and in Nazi Germany it was the constant
repetition of words in daily life that
his professional experience said and his
horrible personal experience was that's
what had the most profound effect so on
this Robert J lift and his analysis of
these um various people who've escaped
they had different methods but he said
there were two basic Chinese government
methods one is your deconstructed to use
a post-modern term as an individual
so your individuality your social
networks so ideally they'd get you in
thought reform prison but they're not
just prison the government did thought
reform classes that people voluntarily
signed up for so if you wanted to get
ahead in China you'd sign up for your
certificate
and in modern universities what's
happening is people decide
the only way to go you have a very
successful career You know despite what
they tell you teaching doesn't matter
they really um as a teacher I could have
told you that right at the start of this
interview yeah but they don't they play
I Don't Love glossy brochures yeah
um what the only thing that bothered
about is Publications and if you can
bring in research money
and they they really don't care
so those people they they've I've seen
it happen and I think you know the guy
wrote Darkness at noon Arthur Kessler
it's a brilliant book about being
imprisoned in a totalitarian it's a
novel
but he did this very funny little short
article where he caught I think he
called it the commissars and the yogi he
said people are divided into two types
the yogi is the spiritualist dreamer and
the commissar you'll know them if you've
you you know Constantine but if you've
ever had any engagement with any
bureaucracy you know what a commissar is
he's the person with the clipboard and
the power and the universities have
created these institutions within the
University where you don't have to be
that good you can climb the greasy pole
by being a commissar by enforcing
language codes
and guess what you set up a language
code unit I think Leeds has now got some
harassment units so good job I left but
um and guess what when you have a unit
devoted to finding harassment you'll
know this from the Soviet example guess
what an awful lot of harassment is found
because they have to justify their own
existence
and then the inefficiencies are telling
me whether this is just made up but the
um they measure productivity by stupid
for example weight of light bulbs so
what they did is they make the light
bulbs heavier and then you find you
can't see through them but they've met
their targets because they've just
produced bloody heavy light bulbs so and
these These irrationalities are asking
you know what's going wrong you've got
these people in institutions within
institutions that are pushing and then
it becomes a question of again
ironically this is where post-modernism
helps it doesn't matter if they believe
in it
so this concept of belief there are
various fascinating Postman ways of
thinking about it you've got a young
child and I'm guessing it's Nikolai
isn't it he doesn't know I'm stalking
you he doesn't know he's done more
research for this interview than we have
um he doesn't know Christmas yet
but oh sorry that's a bit of another I
don't know whether you will celebrate
Christmas it is yeah it's I'm thinking
I'm trying to desperately scramble I
think yeah yeah whatever no no New Year
father Frost right father Frost yeah
but if you wanted to explain that you
will eventually explain that to him or
he'll get his presence and be all
chuffed look there's a concept where as
usual writes about the concept of we
pretend to pretend to believe and what
he means
as adults no one will say We Believe In
Father Christmas but actually we believe
in the children's innocence even when
the children have worked out this is all
nonsense we need to believe in those
children believing
so there are levels of belief and
there's another funny example I think
there's an Ethiopian tribe called the Dr
Jose I think it is and they're
Christians and they believe in fast fast
days and they believe for some bizarre
reason the leopard is a Christian animal
so but on Fast days when the leopard's
supposed to be fasting which they
believe he does they still guard all
their livestock
so we have this idea that primitive
people have primitive beliefs now they
have beliefs that they realize tie the
in the community together and they pick
and choose what they truly believe it's
actually quite sophisticated and we as
thicker westerners patronizingly but
apply this to Modern institutions and
what you get is there will be some of
these commissars and you'll have
experience or know of this from the
Soviet Union who are born again nutty
commissars but there are others who are
doing it for completely manipulative of
course cynical reasons of course and
this is why you have to
look you've got those people who are
True Believers and they are the ones
that are driving this and they have
created in the universities and in the
media and in the corporate world and in
sport and we could go on an incentive
structure and remember people respond to
incentives above all that's that's what
drives you human behavior to a large
extent people will do the thing that
benefits them when to the extent that
they're able to assess that so you've
got these True Believers and then the
rest of us we are fighting over that 80
85 percent in the middle of people who
will go in either direction which is why
a small number of extremists can change
the course of history because if they
can persuade brainwash manipulate
Inspire whatever the words you want to
use that big majority in the middle they
get to do whatever their program is
whatever their agenda is that that's
more group and
I think it's much worse than you say to
the to in the sense that if these were
evil people who in their technocratic
elitist Vision that got together and
were doing blah blah blah that'd be
quite bad but you can get you can get a
lot more done and you can inspire a lot
more people if you truly believe the
crazy thing that you're selling and I
think these these people it's a religion
it's a cult that they uh some of them
are True Believers and then there's a
large group of people who will go along
with it because it's convenient for them
I'm not disagreeing I think one slight
Nuance I'd add is that there's um
there's a thing called I think it's
super linked is it C Polinsky the songs
no no sorry it's something like
superlinky triangles they're called all
right and it's this weird thing is if
you if you basically do three dots and
then do something in the middle and join
it up and basically you can go by the
time you finish bisecting all these
angles you get a fractal shape
and all you're doing is repeating
um a pattern a very simple pattern so
one interpretation of this is that again
some of these people don't believe but
if you're in an environment where
there's a certain it goes without saying
you do this in your local environment if
you do one little act a similar act
happens somewhere else and cross Society
you get this immensely symmetrical
fractal pattern agreed
um so that again is slightly it doesn't
it it's not so much about belief
but it's a it's about the power and the
enforcement of the belief on other
people I agree with you but but what I'm
trying to suggest is the enforcement can
be quite subliminally it's in um the
Nazi case in Nazi Germany within Jewish
uh Holocaust Scholars there is a slight
Division I think they're called The
intentionalists Who interpret what
happened mostly As Hitler's personal but
there's also a group called
structuralists and I'm giving a broad
divide but there's a guy called Raul
hillberg who wrote this it's it's a it's
in some ways horrible uh beautiful
Rising but horrible it's a three volume
you can get a one volume but the the
whole thing is three volumes called the
annihilation of the European Jews and
what's unique about it is he was
obsessed with the bureaucratic evidence
so it's the evidence of at the most
lowest level and there's a small
pamphlet he did separately about the
Reich span which is the um the state
Network system Railway
and get how sick this is he was talking
about the bureau the bureau the
bureaucracy creates an environment where
structurally things happen that never
would have on their own and he gives the
haunting example of
um they had an internal accounting
system and people moved to the death
camps as if there were bags of grain and
if you were under 11 you went free on
the internal accounting system this is
how divorced from Humanity but the point
Raul Helberg and he's been criticized
from other people who prefer to
emphasize the intentionality of all
these things I like most things in life
my suspicion is the truth somewhere in
the middle
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
but I just think it's a slight mistake
sometimes to fail to pay very very close
attention to the way these things can
occur on their own because they're part
of a structure they're not on their own
though you still have to have the hit
layer at the top
and then the structures will provide
whatever the Hitler at the top once
provided so it's a combination like you
say the truth is in the middle the
bureaucracy of in its on its own has the
ability to carry out the worst of things
or the best of things depending on what
it is that is being sent down from the
top right but it is the ideologues at
the top that determine the course of how
that goes and that's why alternative
institutions to what we've got now are
so important that's why New Media is
breaking the mold you talk about dumbing
down well what are we doing here we're
dumbing up right no no can I I'll give
you a personal example because I'm
reading all this bizarre stuff there's a
guy in this state called Henry Abramson
who's a rabbi
um who does some amazing because I'm
getting into Old Testament type
scripture stuff from a literary point of
view and he breaks down the talmud and
the Torah and the midrash and there's a
brilliant scholar David boyerin sorry
Daniel boyerin who's I'd give him the
prize for the best title I've read in
recent times it's Socrates and the fat
rabbis he's written a book and he's a
fascinating devout rabbinical scholar
and it's your point I'm I can get all
this
on the tinternet it's absolutely amazing
but without sounding pump away I will
sound pompers if you've got pre-existing
reading skills and cultural Hinterland
and background you can make use of all
this stuff
but there are a whole generation of
students I've left behind who don't have
this
and Frank for Ada makes a really funny
comment he said in one of his books he
was he criticized the fact that some of
his students in the humanities can get a
whole degree without having read a
complete book
he said this is outrageous and he said
after he'd published the book he got
contacted by University administrator he
said oh God what's going to be said now
and the administrator said yes you're
correct and he's like what he goes
you're correct and this is a wonderful
thing because it just shows we have
multi-learning platforms
and this is the point there are struck I
don't mean to bang on about the
structural elements but
and we can all we can do is what we can
do
but I've also think it made me think
because I think you you you sometimes
get frustrated and Strikes because you
want you do want practical answers now
you understand why
and here's just a slightly odd thought I
just think we could all be a bit more
canny you know um on bitradio 4 where
I'll stop listening to that as well
um is it Robinson in the morning
the guy who does the interviews Nick
Robinson and have you ever heard him let
anyone speak for more than five words
before he interrupts them
I have actually I think Nick Robinson is
not as bad as others but I take your
point they all interrupt all right sorry
well I might I picked the wrong person
but it is one of the reasons I just
stopped listening was it's not because
I'm being petty it's just I want to
listen to people speak I was just
wondering whether there are more
techniques whereby the one thing on
radio they can't stand as silent
when they've interrupted you for the
third time just don't say anything until
they say are you there can you say
something I'll say I'll respond when you
stop interrupting me I do think they're
very practical sounds like a very small
example but I do think there are
practical things and you've um because I
stalk you online
there's the one where you're discussing
uh this interview gets more troubling
every minute
there's London stop being English the
whole John Clues yeah and there's a
fascinating thing it is you've got it on
your site where you highlight but it was
the power of logic and forgive me it's
not been snippy but you weren't saying
anything it wasn't you know David well
my entire the tragic of my entire career
as I say very obvious things and
everyone goes oh my God that's amazing
but don't think it's funny you just said
yeah if Scotland sorry if London was 50
Scottish would it be fair to say it's
less English
and but you had you were forgive me I
think you got in on that discussion
because you have an ethnic background
yeah okay that wasn't a wipe there was
two mixed race presenters
um three
people from ethnic minorities discussing
has lungs and stopped being white
something
and um but you just said if we use the
example of scottishness
and would that would it be like and the
look of absolute confusion but it's your
point about it that's why I said it
tonight it's a cult it's a cult that's
why it produces the Blank Stare when I
give them the logical example because
suddenly they're confronted with it's it
with reality or maybe they're using a
stadium mode cool
two touching on universities and
isn't the problem that what this system
produces is an absence of meritocracy
from my own industry not teaching but
comedy I saw well we both saw it this
cult ideology whatever you want to call
it come in and infect an entire industry
and what happened in the Edinburgh
Festival the moment I knew that the
Edinburgh Festival was finished as an
institution was because you go and see
shows that are patently not four and
five star shows they were then given
four and five stars because they
espoused the ideology they said the
right words they had the right views the
right opinions Etc and once that happens
meritocracy is done because you're it's
not an accurate refraction of the
quality of the work
isn't that what's happening at
universities yeah there's layers layers
to respond to that and before I forget
it was talking about comedy I came
across it was in Nietzsche's birth of
tragedy he referred to Comics they're
the toxic discharge of absurdities
nausea which I thought it was uh it
doesn't sound like a compliment
but no but um the merry talk to say yeah
I went because I lived in Edinburgh for
all that time I went to
um a lot of the The Fringe and it
strikes me that it's very similar to the
BBC
it's not what you know it's who you know
and it is surprising though because I
think there's a there's a bit of unity
between us in the sense of background in
the sense you're in a comedy industry if
I can call it that
and you would have thought the most
basic thing you do in comedy is tell
jokes and the most basic elements of a
joke is and this is just obvious to
comedians that you don't know in advance
what's funny you push the boundaries or
you turn into Michael McIntyre
or the weirdest I'd love to get your
opinion on Frankie Boyle what happened
to him
um
from a seemingly normal you know
something telling terribly cruel jokes
to going full-on woke
um strange things happen but anyway well
just before you go on and I I know I've
been hogging the microphone I should say
Michael McIntyre is a fantastic comedian
he's absolutely brilliant he's
technically brilliant he's fantastic at
making a large number of people alive
he's not necessarily an intellectual
person's comedian but but you know if
you're going to be selling out stadiums
that Michael McIntyre is Brill and
France and I both have a lot of respect
for him yeah I have my it's completely
personal well this is why I mentioned
Frankie ball in the same sentence when
he was funny
I'm a dog but my interior monologue
gives Notes From The Underground
Dostoevsky going around in my head so
I'm not a yardstick and I'm not
professional comic no and I can imagine
to do what he does he's incredible
Michael McIntyre is in supremely skilled
comedian yeah just it's just not for you
yeah but the point I was trying to make
is the absence of meritocracy or when
you're a road meritocracy
the institution collapses and that's any
institution and my point is isn't that
what's happening at universities now
where you do a literature degree you
don't have to read the book
you know you don't have the depth of
study you don't have the intellectual
rigor if you don't have the intellectual
rigor then you then it's not going to be
an accurate reflection of your ability
in that particular subject if it's not
in that particular subject then
ultimately the degree that you were
given is worthless
yeah and that I mentioned I went to
University in 85 and it was about 12 of
people and then my career actually
matched when I was doing my PhD it was
in the second year of my PhD which I
think was about 91. I personally
benefited because there was a massive
expansion and I got to do tutorials and
this is 1991 I think Edinburgh I was
paid 18 pounds an hour
it was like happy days I did as many
hours as I possibly could but that was
because they expanded the numbers and
that's when you notice it's your point
when you expand the numbers in and of
itself that reduces quality because
you've gone away from this selective and
I've always joked that you know I'd have
loved to play for Liverpool the main
football team the main thing stopping me
is fat and talentless so I could
probably still play for Everton
you're gonna get destroyed off to listen
to by Anton I'd like to say I'm a fast
runner but I'm not even though um but so
that's the sheer expansion dilutes and
but then I I I've got mixed views
because I'm a massive believer in
elitism so
it really annoys me that Richard grannon
had this he's a Spartan life coaching
isn't it because I had this concept of
Spartan therapy you leave businessmen on
their underpants on the top of the hill
in Wales where I live and Shout at them
a lot and they'll either recover or like
the Spartans that they die on the
mountain so but um where was it going
with this yeah we were talking about
meritocracy within the university system
yeah and so it's it's the expansion the
numbers the sheer numbers
so and then there's the fact the minute
they start paying
so I remember there was one point in my
career where I was marking and one of
the commissars said to me uh there's a
massive disparity between the marks
we're both giving
so I showed them the comment side main
said oh I see I said what do you mean
said you're marking the old way
I said I missed the memo
that said we're now but this is how it
works what did that mean what's the old
way I was using before the expansion
what would have been a first two one and
a two-tune nowadays then this is the
guardian which I know you two are
massive fans of they'd have things at
the guardian University League table
well we're back to the Soviet
manipulation statistics and the guardian
League table one of the criteria for how
high you are is how many firsts do
people leave the university with because
that is a sign of the quality of the
institution or not if that feeds back
there's a feedback loop tell you what
Lads if we give out a lot more first we
go up the table I was like hmm
everyone's doing it
and why if if you're recruiting let's
just say you you you use my old
standards and the students and their
parents the helicopter parents who by
the way now attend I think Frank Frady
again writes about this they attend open
days
so I remember saying any questions I
used to do open days with the admissions
tutor
and any questions and the parents and
the kids just sat there and thinking
I was gonna say you do know you're gonna
have to come to University and write
some essays on your own but
I don't think that's true
because I do know of parents helping
this
you know professional parents helping
those kids write essays
Paul one of the things that I notice in
my career in education is towards the
end it was a realization that what
schools were was essentially a factory
for harvesting data which then
successive governments use to prove that
they were doing a good job in education
so we for instance do
the way that the government deduced that
they were doing a good job in primary
schools is a set which kids took at the
age of 11.
we had to teach them grammar now the way
we taught them grammar didn't in fact
help them in any particular way with
their writing didn't tape teach them how
to be better writers how to construct a
sentence uh punctuation or any of that
all it taught them was how to pass a
grammar test
so we used to cram the kids full of this
useless information that in two weeks
time they would have forgotten about
simply to pass a test but once they've
passed the test and the kit and the
school gets 85 percent the government
can go look up what a good job we're
doing tick is that what the university
sector is like yeah I've mentioned it
before the idea the Soviet when
everything's driven by statistics you
know statistics are eminently fakeable
and this is why I right at the very
beginning everyone should be trained in
statistics to know their weaknesses
statistics are incredibly powerful and
they get a bad rap because they're so
often misused because people don't know
how to interpret them if you don't know
the difference in the median then you
know the arithmetic arithmetic average I
might know it but I can't say it
um this has this has an impact and
you're completely correct what that
allows when everything's data driven the
people in charge of the data are all
powerful
but leads for example that was one of
the former I believe it was one of the
former Vice chancellors sir Alan
langland and he was going to get rid of
the classics department at Leeds and
they had to get an international
petition to stop him and at the moment
uh University of turkey in Finland which
I've been to their Classics Department's
under threat and it's because of you why
if you're obsessed with the statistics
and
um guess what the classics are quite
difficult
so to commit to teaching student the
class of which I would argue is the
single most important thing we could do
on a practical level to improve things
so if we've got a slight tangent the
whole issue about non-binary stuff and
trans read over its Metamorphoses
and it's relates to narcissus but um is
it Larry lario p
um is the mother of Narcissus and she
asks a blind Seer a forecaster of the
future what her son's outcome was going
to be and he's blind because initially
he stood on no he was he was um Juno and
Jupiter there's a point to this but it's
because Juno and Jupiter the god Jupiter
and his wife Juno
Teresa was the name of the Seer he stood
on two snakes copulating
and because of the coat is Interrupters
they
um made him turned him into a woman
as a punishment don't shoot the
messenger so he's turned into woman so
he then manages to get the snakes back
and he's turned back to a man so Juno
and Jupiter arguing over who has no
sexual pleasure a man or a woman so he
thought I know we'll ask the Teresa's
direct to research I think his name is
uh we'll ask him what he thinks as he's
experienced both
and then he gives the wrong answer he
says the woman has too much pleasure so
she makes him blind
so then he makes the prediction about
narcissism when narcissus comes along it
says anova's metamorphosis narcissus was
beloved of men and women
so he's basically Sam Smith ahead of his
time
um but my point is the by the you know
there's a clue in the title
Metamorphoses it's about changing it's
about fluidity
if these poor kids could read Ovid and
have it explained to them intelligently
oh that's interesting about identity as
fluid this has been known since then the
beginning of time it's when you get the
mermaid idealogs
that these type of ideas get a it's the
dumb down version
B it has no roots with actual Community
knowledge which is what the Greek myths
had and it's just hilarious because the
Greek gods were they intervened and were
jealous of humans they did loads of mad
stuff because guess what the Greeks
understood their gods were just ways of
thinking
it wasn't
ideological and the gods would do
contradictory things guess what life's
contradictory live phase you never know
all the point about hubris and Nemesis
all these things life's gonna bite you
in the ass that is what the Greeks
taught now my point would be when
universities because we're talking about
how could the BBC improve how could
universities improve well tell you what
next time some stupid ignoramus from HR
and but that's basically anyone from HR
comes to give us a training course
why you know Classics departments around
the world are under threat I would pay
for the classics Department to teach
internal training using the Socratic
method like Richard granlon said using
the Greek myths
and provide substantial stuff worth
engaging with I could imagine a load of
academics and this is the bad faith part
of our academic sit on these training
courses and the vast majority aren't
stupid and they're not ideological and
they're sat there thinking I don't
believe we're doing this
and the vice chances of University of
Leeds will say we're a wonderful
community and we're all doing and look
you've just been trained on gender
fluidity
and she must know how staff think most
of them think this is nonsense on stilts
and that's the bad faith gets replicated
but she it's it's a Dutch woman who's in
charge of leads and she'll be on a
hundreds of thousands of pounds the
propagating what she must know deep down
her staff think is intellectually
vacuous
so if that's the leader of a man lead is
a big university approximately 35 000
students
if that's the leadership it goes back to
my advisory point if he's a lord
and he's espousing bad faith and he's
showing no moral character
and it's you're totally right programs
like this the fact that Douglas Murray
puts himself out there I worry I think
Richard granin has said I'll worry about
uh Jordan Peterson his own health
because I think it seems to have taken
on an awful lot like a savior complex
um but it does it I I think you're right
a Constantine that perhaps we could go
both ways perhaps obviously you keep
doing this type of stuff but I don't
think we should ever stop holding them
to account because they're not doing
their jobs
um yeah uh yeah I just I I don't think
you're going to get very far with that I
think you have to we have to let go of
the old institutions well you but then
forgive me that's the type of defeaters
thing I was saying not defeat us at all
the end of one thing is always the birth
of something new well why couldn't we
though
as a society and as public figure well
I'm not a public figure but public
figures why couldn't we argue for things
like proper teaching of Classics you can
argue for anything no no I mean she's
not going to get it no no well I'm
saying strategically so for example your
your idea about the internet if you look
at what Jordan Peterson's doing with the
Book of Genesis
um that and it's it's interesting it's
it's it is he's been criticized because
it's a certain type of male demographic
who are lost so the incel type community
but he can sell out Stadium when uh I
think it goes beyond the Intel Community
his audience no no no no I've said
you've been criticized for that yeah
yeah but my point is that particular
demographic feel lost they lack meaning
yes and I think it's the beginning of
your book on uh love letter to the West
available all good bookshops yeah you
actually quote sols Nixon and say when
when the when a tree is rotten it's cool
and it's about spirituality and I think
you've both said you say grace before
meals no there's there's a loss of
spirituality and I understand you're not
going to get the toothpaste back in the
tube you can't expect everyone suddenly
to become religious
but you can connect with the wisdom of
the classics absolutely but my point is
I think we could do it more aggressively
I don't think it's Pie in the Sky
um for example with Russian again Jordan
Peterson and others um I was going to
say bang gone but I'm a massive
Dostoevsky fan where there's an
Institute Cervantes Instituto Cervantes
Spanish culture there's the academy for
all says Etc was the Russian is the one
timing's not great for that but
we have to wrap up because you can see
how much we've enjoyed this yes we've
overrun by about 45 minutes but
the answer to the problem that you're
talking about is for you to get on the
internet and give people that classical
education in the form of YouTube
lectures that's how this gets addressed
starting there and working our way up to
bigger institutions over time they're
universities that are starting up that
are going to offer a different type of
curriculum that's how this gets solved
there's people like you going out there
and making something for people to enjoy
because as we've seen with this and with
all sorts of other shows there's an
appetite out there for that so uh I I
challenge you uh yeah but you know why
I'm not tempted to because there's
people like Chris Watkins Henry Abramson
I think there's too many people doing
too much stuff in a way
I'd much rather try and help them
because he Chris Watkins is just
brilliant the the level he can explain
darada and Foucault at such a level of
relative Simplicity given the difficulty
of the content that I think people would
be shocked
suddenly
um why is this why the fouca is a
bogeyman why is this so fascinating but
Paul my point to you would be
um I think everybody has a role to play
in this so for instance Constantine can
write and deliver a speech much better
than me that will go viral I well I'm
not going to go into the Oxford Union
write a speech and deliver it what I can
do is I can write comedy that Lampoon's
the sacred cows of the day the jacindas
all the rest of it and that people will
share and that people and I read the
comments and people go nailed it spot on
absolutely
we've all got our part to play well
except can I give you an example of
online yeah uh unheard magazine which I
really like we all do the great great
publication so there's uh Belgian I
think he's a postdoc he wrote a
brilliant article my massive fan of Jean
beaudrian's work who again he's like an
Old Testament Prophet he's been
misinterpreted he really slagged off
Modern Life yeah brilliant article about
John bergerard and how he's relevant to
modern day America
I normally don't look at the comments
look down at the comments and someone
said no he could have said this in three
paragraphs it's like no he couldn't
he's Belgian he's probably his fifth
language brilliant I thought was a very
good article yeah I'm a boat yard to
pump myself up but I'm basically a
bojard expert I thought it was brilliant
um snotty comments what I wrote and I
normally don't and the irony is my
online pseudonym is Theodora dorno
because I don't like using my real name
who's a cultural Marxist so I wrote your
comment is typical of the Twitter
generation everything has to be said in
so many characters it's a great article
leave them alone so he basically replied
Theodore Donna happened to be a great
musicologist so he said if you are the
spirit of Theodore O'Donnell go off and
tinkle your ivories and I said I will go
off and tinkle me ivories if you go off
and scrub your nan
full stop and my point is this isn't
great even I understand that's not
Socratic method yeah but this is the
point that online
and I do think there's uh Peter
slaughtered like the German philosopher
said that more communication builds more
conflict this idea that necessarily do
more
I think no you do more targeted stuff do
better stuff you know fail try again
fail better
um so sometimes I think you shouldn't
have below the line comments
so there's magazines Compact magazine is
one of them in in the states
um the critic there's another magazine
here online great stuff that you're
talking about they actually don't think
there's no comment
and that's something else maybe that
could be addressed as the idea this I
what the technology does brilliantly is
encourage loads and loads of
interactivity I would argue
significantly too much
and we actually need to find ways to
winnow it to filter it
um and that would improve things well
Paul it's been a sensational interview
we've both it's been brilliant we've
loved every second of it thank you so
much for coming on the question that we
always end our interviews is with is
what is the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be I'm gonna cheat and give you two very
quick ones and we will do a couple of
questions for our locals only that only
they will get this year as well
um I've said one of them I said I
wouldn't do because I've got a friend in
the village Becky and her husband's
called Adolf which is another story
um but Becky I said uh dog poo bags
I live in the countryside and I just
think it's the perfect embodiment so to
speak of
um virtue signaling people will leave
them full of dog crap because that's
what they're there for in the middle of
nowhere because there isn't a bin I mean
now can you explain to me why is that a
passive aggressive why do people do that
um it strikes me that it's this passive
aggressive there isn't a been I'm making
some type of point
but it just strikes me it's this failure
to Think Through the consequences that
will now be there unless somebody else
picks it up moves it because there
aren't any bins because it's called
Countryside your Muppet
um so that will be there for the next
Thousand Years unless it's a
biodegradable bag the other thing is tea
bags which no offense it was a lovely
cup of tea but I'm it's such a simple
thing that's
T you know the T they put in tea bags is
absolutely atrocious quality everybody
uses tea bags and if you're awoken
economically focused
it the the tea they put into crap so
people in the developing world who grow
tea don't get a good price because it's
the fannings off the floor of the
factory
and it's so you can buy great quality
tea use a teapot use a strainer hardly
any more effort and the whole world of
tea is out there but tea bags are it's
this encapsulation of the easy I don't
think it is particularly easy it's bad
for you bad quality tea bleached bags
glue in the bags so you're all killing
yourselves and I drink great tea
and on that note thank you so much for
coming on people want to find you online
ironically enough where is the best
place to do well this is what's funny
you're gonna have to deal with all the
complaints I don't have a mobile phone
yeah
um I don't have an online presence
um I'm like high diggers run off to the
German forest I live in the Welsh Hills
so anyone who wants to have a go please
just bother you to
sounds good to me that is what they
usually do we're going to ask you a
couple of questions from our supporters
that only they will get to see an answer
on our locals too but for now Paul been
great to have you on thank you so much
does the doctor think that the lack of
access to universities from the working
classes has resulted in the current
situation for mostly middle class upper
class kids going into uni and creating
strange woke religions as they have
never known in inverted commas hardship
previously
[Music]